back at Evo the drywallers are closing
up the walls on the fourth floor
following close behind are the tapers
they use a device called a bazooka to
blast through a unit sealing the cracks
between the drywall with wet tea
fast as the work seems to be progressing
there's a crisis brewing in the
background
unfortunately long before I came on
board somebody went to the owner and
said you'll have your building May first
then all by the way here here comes GM
and now here figure out a way to make it
happen well early on it's sort of all
kind of makes sense and pencils out he
can kind of tweak things around and it
looks pretty good but then as you you
get into it and we're into it now
the reality comes sets in it's like what
crap we might need a little bit more
time when Jim and his team revise the
detailed finishing schedule for all 23
floors they realize that to make the may
first end date the drywall is now two
months behind schedule
Scott's Zbornak is the supervisor for
Martin Brothers the drywall
subcontractor they have some guys in the
office who figured out a schedule with
the ownership a long time ago and they
were saying we should have been at a
certain point but from my aspect I mean
we were on the job early we're right
behind the guys upstairs so there's been
a lot of questions that weren't answered
and I don't know how we got two months
behind if we are has nothing new with us
we've been given the date and we we will
make every attempt to try to make you
reach a point in time where reality
begins to set in to where you're
thinking you know what we've still got
this much work to do in this much time
is it really realistic and so we're we
haven't given up hope but we're we're
concerned my concern for sure
at the weekly Foreman's meeting Jim lays
his cards out on the table the reality
is is I think setting in so now we've
got to just pencil it out and it may not
be May 1st it may be July 1st and then
that's the oh crap and then we have to
figure out what we can do if anything